eviction moratorium will and in phases
starting on Wednesday it impacts both
commercial and residential tenants 8
News no reporter Kristen Drummond is
live now in the newsroom with more on
what you need to know
Kristen Sasha the moratorium was always
set to expire on June 30th it was put in
place at the end of March amid record
job losses from kovat 19 layoffs now the
latest emergency directive allows
landlords to start charging rent again
that includes seeking unpaid rent from
the last few months the state recommends
landlords and tenants enter into a lease
addendum and promissory note that
guarantees a repayment plan and protects
both parties the state suggests each
payment be no more than 15% of the
current monthly rent realtor says it's
important tenants and landlords
understand the conditions even if a
tenant decides to move out you're not
it's not being forgiven you do have to
pay it back and even if your lease is
going to expire within the next couple
of months you're expected to pay that
back at some point if you cannot afford
the repayment amount the state
encourages to seek legal aid landlords
can start the eviction process on August
1st if a tenant is considered a nuisance
and those who decide to not pay rent can
be evicted beginning on September 1st
that's also the date landlords can
charge late fees and penalties again the
moratorium has officially ended though
for anyone staying in hotels motels
motor courts Inns and boarding as well
as lodging houses the governor's latest
directive also impacts commercial
tenants and we have all the information
on our website
8 News now.com reporting live in the
newsroom Kristen Drummond